hey guys this is dennis the founder
thing here i'm david griffin your
resident comic book in video game guru
and this is our review of the walking
dead season 4 episode 11 claim ok so
this episode I thought it was ok last
week I liked more I do like this one
better than the mid-season premiere the
one with Karl's is whining the whole
time it but at the same time I think
with this episode there was only kind of
two storylines going on and it was
mainly the Carl and Michonne and Rick
storyline right and they just I felt
like they stretched like a little bit of
story to like a whole episode right I
enjoyed I like the Michonne's characters
getting flushed out more that some the
you and I have not seen the comic books
as much and I liked it we're getting
some backstory I liked you know Carl and
hers are a little banter about you know
like the whole thing about the clear
room all you can ask one question we
learn that she you know did have a kid
and that's interesting never knew that I
mean just you know i like i like that
dialogue but i guess i need you to help
me educate me on this maybe you you know
youtuber either guys that watch think
hero fans you know you guys always say
you know day look at this what you
missed look at you not paying attention
to I didn't know what exactly happened
this episode in terms of story i I'm all
for Rick's great escape from the house I
mean it was interesting it was little
suspenseful is kind of cool seen it but
I'm like what does that do for the story
I want to know like you know we're
watching true detective right now a lot
of story going on there I'm not getting
a lot of story out of this episode of
walking dead even you know I'm sure some
people who are like fanboys won't agree
with this but walking dead is notorious
for stretching out their stories there
are some good moments like moments with
Michonne I enjoyed that but the rest of
it I'm like Rick getting out of the
house and like it's a if it feels like
how remember when lost didn't have like
an end point and they were just that's
what I left the show any repairs
watching LA los got better as soon as
they as soon as they decide okay we're
gonna end with this many seasons this is
our end point it start to form together
and I think that's the issue with
walking dead is very successful and so
they're taking little bits of story and
stretching him out so there was a little
bit of story in this episode it just
they took a whole episode you know
because mostly it was basically
to get Rick Carl and Michonne on the
move to find that there was a community
everybody's now everybody's going to the
kyani right now so that was the story
right that right that was the story
right that they extended for a very long
period of time and then you had the
other side with Glenn and Tara and these
new that soldier guy and the doctor we
find out they be chargin Abraham that no
the doctor that I don't know this well
the mullet out there on the mullet dr.
the mullet dr. it's good-looking mullet
that knows how the whole zombie
apocalypse started but the hotel they
will tell them they're late top secret
right so you have that but that was a
small portion that was probably like
maybe like 15 20 percent of the episode
right so there was a little bit of story
there and ultimately at the very end
they're going back there going back with
Glenn right to find Maggie and that's
the thing I thought I felt I felt the
stretchiness I felt that the story
stretching out and it's unfair to
compare it and probably a lot of you out
there gonna ask me well Dave you like
the comic book some books are basically
the same and it's true but for some
reason when I'm watching this show week
after week I'm getting a little bit
tired just seeing a bunch of shootouts
with zombies like don't go wrong I like
the way that action sequence was shot
with Rick in the house I don't think it
had much do with the story but i like
seeing Rick you know it was shot well
was on suspense with the guy sleeping
above him and him trapped under there
trying to get his water and hide all the
evidence like that was interesting but
again the story it's like a game of
thrones you don't see grant it's a much
different story we don't see like the
game of thrones cast going and killing
White Walkers every episode you know
like their equivalent of zombies I guess
if you want to call it so it's like I
don't know it's repetitive that's what
that's what it is is it's not anything
new you know we had the prison all right
that was cool but then you know we had
that Holt the flu story line at the
beginning of the season that was kind of
repetitive so I think that's what it is
i mean i like the parts with Michonne
yeah I like that look good okay and then
also I did find it kind of strange that
Carl was like he got really upset when
he had to when he brought up Judas name
and accidently and then he remember
oh my gosh she's missing / could be dead
right but then later had no qualms about
asking Michonne about her head I'm
assuming dead dead or missing child
right which I was like that doesn't make
any sense ok you're here and maybe it is
the whole age thing we're really he is
supposed to be how old is he's in the
Congo the comic book somebody one of you
who think the fans pointed out that I
believe in issue 82 I think it's like
eight okay summersweet eight ten years
old I believe he's a little guy yeah
yeah that probably makes a little more
send you someone that age just not
knowing any better but at his age now
like what is he like 13 14 right I mean
I think yeah I'd again I wish to this in
the last review I don't want to
criticize Carl because it's not the
actors fault that he's grown I mean if
you already happened in the convo you
can draw some by the same age for years
and but time you know move season the
season but just I don't know if the
actor is able to carry that emotional
weight quite yet I mean I haven't seen
him do anything else besides walking
dead so sometimes when he has these
scenes where he's letting out a lot of
emotion and like I don't know if I buy
it from the actor when the actor not so
I don't know so for me then it's more of
a question of okay well if if they're
gonna write this character and he's
obviously growing older why not adapt to
this actor being older now why not right
basically what I feel like is there
writing him like he was still 10 years
old eight or nine of nine years old when
he clearly isn't me looks like you'd be
16 on holy actress but he looks older I
mean yeah I don't know I just wish I
want to see I was before I'm getting
into a thought here that we know the
show's expand to 16 episodes these last
two seasons and a lot of you agreed with
us and we brought this up before is that
I don't think the show needs to be 16
episodes same with Game of Thrones it's
like I wish it was more than ten but I
think once you get past 13 episodes this
season I think you're starting to
stretch the story out a little bit and
they have a good story they have a good
cassock that can just focus the story a
little more let's just get to this
location let's get to this next you know
safe haven that's going to be safe we're
all going to be safe instead of you know
just I don't know they're just like you
said stretching it out like that yeah I
feel like maybe like the
last two episodes could have been one
episode yeah just combined it right
right because our moments i like i like
the parts of the Michonne it was a
suspenseful moment with Rick in the
house under the bed it was suspenseful
but again as a story I'm like it
compared to true detective I don't see I
don't see the purpose it is to the store
like what does that do for Rick's
character him escape I mean rich the
badass i love Rick I love Rick in the
comics but what does that tell us about
Rick him escaping the house but I guess
it he's a badass maybe that's it I don't
know oh you already knew he's a bad boys
it looks at that I mean there's a lot of
repetition and that's why I like I was
talking about the whole Carl thing
people like oh but they were just
building it up I'm like no they've kind
of done this before I'm for they just
keep repeating it over and over right so
I don't know I it's a hugely successful
show I'm never so their nachos I don't
think they're gonna change anything
about it listen to us I think I was good
but I'm excited for next week cuz we're
going to see more Daryl Daryl and Beth I
like that I said like from the video
games from tell tells video games
reminds me of a Clementine a little bit
so I like the hole Darrell and Beth
dynamic I'm looking forward to seeing
that next week okay alright guys so
that's what we thought the episode you
can post your accounts bowl on the
website thank Eric amor on our YouTube
channel think hero pro make sure you
subscribe to that Oh y'all spot us on
Twitter with daddy's want to come chat
with us about Walking Dead which are
loving about the episode the whole arc
of this season I let us know it's at
think hero i'm at griffin de and we also
have a Facebook page that's face vodacom
/ think Cairo fans make sure to LIKE
that page and share our video
you